michel debré candidat à la présidence
pour convaincre et gagner
el mout 8 à moscou l'europe mise
toujours sur le dialogue
l'alcoolisme en france 70 mille morts
chaque année question de temps à 20h30
et l'âge et messieurs bonsoir sur le
plan international cette journée marquée
par de voyage important celui du
chancelier allemand schmidt à moscou et
celui du souverain pontife au brésil une
véritable épreuve d'endurance pour jean
paul ii treize mille kilomètres et 44
discours en 12 jours le brésil qui est
le pays au monde où il ya le plus de 4
800 millions s'est longuement préparé
l'on a même procédé au nettoyage du
fameux christ de coke aux badauds dont
la statue géante les bras en croix
domine toute la région de rioz john r
mais le pape n'est pas encore à
rio-de-janeiro il a atterri à 17 heures
heure de paris dans la capitale brasilia
où il a accueilli le président de la
république et de brasilia voici notre
envoyé spécial jean claude berri
treize mille kilomètres en ce jour 44
discours à prononcer le pape jean paul
ii entame au brésil une véritable
épreuve d'endurance dans un pays grand
comme seize fois la france et qui compte
100 millions de baptisés
ce voyage est le septième du pontificat
en l'espace de vingt mois brasilia la
filme la ville en forme de croix voulue
par oscar niemayer accueille donc la
première le chef de l'église catholique
brasilia qui se voulait la ville
égalitaire où toutes les couches
sociales pourrait cohabiter en fait le
brassage social n'a pas eu lieu et les
plus démunis doivent vivre dans les
banlieues pauvres un symbole pour tous
le brésil où la richesse et si mal
partagé ou le plus riche presse le plus
fort je suis au brésil en mission
pastorale et religieuses a déclaré le
pape
dès son arrivée au moment où le pape
s'envoler pour le brésil le saint-siège
faisait connaître le point de vue du
vatican sur la question de jérusalem le
vatican demande entre autres primes ou
que le caractère global de jérusalem en
tant que patrimoine sacré commun aux
trois religions monothéistes chrétienne
musulmane et juive soient garantis par
des mesures appropriées
secundo la liberté religieuse dans tous
ses aspects doit être sauvegardé pour
les trois religions
troisièmement que l'ensemble des droits
acquis par les différentes communautés
sur les sanctuaires soient protégés
revenons-en à l'autre voyage très
important de la journée le chancelier
allemand helmut schmidt est d'arriver à
moscou pour une rencontre avec monsieur
brejnev
celui ci s'est rendu à l'aéroport
douveneau que vous pourrez accueillir
son visiteur programme chargé des
entretiens les problèmes aigus sont
loués par des missiles l'afghanistan le
commerce bilatéral un commentaire de
philippe chatrier brejnev apparemment en
excellente forme physique et accueilli
ce matin le chancelier helmut schmidt
les soviétiques donne un éclat
particulier à la visite de schmidt
la première effectuée moscou par un
leader occidental depuis l'invasion de
l'afghanistan
comme lors des entretiens entre leonid
brejnev du président giscard d'estaing à
varsovie
c'est le problème afghan qui sera au
centre des débats pourtant souligne du
côté allemand que le chancelier schmitt
ne se fait aucune illusion
pour ce qui est d'obtenir des
concessions soviétique sur l'afghanistan
son but est de réaffirmer directement
leader soviétique
la position allemande et européenne
contre helmut schmidt ne cache pas ses
espoirs de faire avancer la détente en
matière d'armement nucléaire de par lots
du rideau de fer
de même les allemands de l'ouest savent
bien que toute amélioration de leurs
rapports avec l'allemagne démocratique
dépend de mossoul quant aux soviétiques
leurs objectifs sont clairs prouver au
monde que malgré la pianiste ans ils ne
sont pas isolés sur le plan diplomatique
et bien à la fin du mois d'où il y aura
en allemagne de l'est en un endroit non
encore fixée une rencontre au sommet
entre les dirigeants des deux allemagnes
le chancelier schmitt est le président
de la rvm serait necker ils s'étaient
rencontrés une première fois lors de la
conférence d'helsinki en 1975 les points
de friction possible entre les deux pays
sont très nombreux mais leurs rapports
sont présentés comme étant actuellement
tout à fait correct monsieur menahem
begin premier ministre israélien était
transportée à l'hôpital oui devra
prendre quelques jours de repos
il avait été pris d'un malaise au cours
d'une séance de la knesset l'assemblée
nationale israélienne pendant un débat
sur une dissolution possible du
parlement projet d'ailleurs rejeté par
une majorité de six voix france monsieur
michel debré annoncé ce matin qu'il
serait candidat à la présidence de la
république monsieur debré à 68 ans il
fut le premier premier ministre du
général de gaulle et la détenue depuis
lors les portefeuilles des affaires
étrangères de la défense de l'économie
et des finances dans divers autres
gouvernements
monsieur debré qui est notre invité qui
sera dans un instant notre invité sur le
plateau de la deux a confirmé dans une
conférence de presse à paris ces
résolutions votre combien jusqu'au soir
du premier ou du second tour
c'est-à-dire pour convaincre et gagner
alors quelques pins cette candidature
est elle ou les milieux politiques une
surprise puisque les la candidature en
elle-même n'est pas une surprise mais la
façon dont elle est annoncée et comporte
deux surprises la première c'est qu'il
soit annoncé sitôt on attendait en effet
cette nouvelle plutôt pour l'automne et
puis la deuxième surprise et bien c'est
ce que vient de dire monsieur michel
debré qui les candidats non seulement
pour témoigner convaincre mais pour
gagner vous dirais que c'est
parfaitement normal qu'un candidat qui
se lancent dans une course comme celle
ci est l'intention de gagner mais
jusqu'ici on avait beaucoup répété que
michel debré se présente est
essentiellement pour faire passer ses
idées ses idées il est vrai qu'il
insiste très fortement là dessus et vous
zone et qu'il ya quelques jours lors de
son voyage en corse il avait déclaré un
autre
me jean-louis les scènes on n'est jamais
si bien servi que par soi même lorsqu'il
s'agit de défendre ses idées alors
quelles sont les idées que monsieur
debré en temps c'est will have a créé
présentait déjà une sorte de programme
présidentiel en quatre points
premièrement redresser l'économie
française par deux moyens la lutte
contre les causes de l'inflation et puis
le développement de l'investissement
deuxième objectif approfondir la
solidarité nationale et ranimer notre
élan vital et c6 permettre à monsieur
debré de répondre deux idées qui lui
sont chers la politique des revenus en
ce qui concerne la solidarité et la
démographie en ce qui concerne l'élan
vital troisième objectif faire renaître
la confiance de la nation et là monsieur
michel debré insiste sur le respect de
l'état républicain et sur l'importance
de l'éducation notamment dans le domaine
de l'histoire et quatrième objectif
rétablir un ordre international ce qui
permet à monsieur michel debré de
reprendre sa doctrine en matière de
défense
et d'insister sur l'ordre monétaire les
accords économiques et la réduction des
armes
quelles sont les conséquences politiques
et notamment webp et les souliers on
peut se demander déjà et de façon
peut-être un peu limité si dans les mois
qui viennent cela ne va pas amener un
certain durcissement du rpr qui n'a pas
à y avoir une sorte de surenchère à
l'opposition d'autant qu'aujourd'hui et
monsieur debré souligne qu'il ne s'agit
que d'une coïncidence
monsieur pierre juillet ancien
conseiller de george pompidou et de
jacques chirac vient de lancer un appel
aussi au rpr alain dalm dans le même
sens
celis ans des présidentielles et bien je
dirais selon la formule un peu familière
que la balle est maintenant dans le camp
de jacques chirac
en résumant est peut-être en déformant
un point un peu la pensée de michel
debré on pourrait dire ceci michel debré
candidats en 81 et jacques chirac
candidat en 88 ce n'est pas si mal
reste à savoir si cela fait les affaires
de jacques chirac or il faudra bien que
d'une façon ou d'une autre le rpr
tranche michel debré jacques chirac sont
d'accord tous les deux sur un même point
c'est que dans l'esprit du gaullisme un
candidat n'est pas le candidat d'un
parti mais il y aura quand même un
congrès qui devra décider du soutien et
je pense que ce sera sans doute une des
crises les plus graves qui aura connu
jusqu'ici
le mouvement gaulliste en deux les gars
monsieur chirac président du rpr
aucune réaction pour le moment monsieur
claude labbé président du groupe
parlementaire
l'assemblée était notre invité antenne
2010 et voici ce qu'il a dit c'est une
démarche parfaitement individuelle et
personnelle qui n'engage absolument pas
notre mouvement no rassemblement pour la
république
les soldes le moment venu en présence
d'un certain nombre de coups de
candidature puisque je m'aperçois qu'il
y en a déjà eu une meilleure n'aura
d'autre et bien notre mouvement se
déterminera et il appuiera dans l'unité
j'en suis certain de toutes ses forces
un candidat et un seul monsieur michel
debré nous l'attendons sur le plateau je
pense qu'il a beaucoup à faire
aujourd'hui et il faut lui pardonner les
deux ou trois minutes de retard qu'il
pourrait appeler monsieur alain krivine
a fait savoir qu'il serait lui aussi
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
pour la ligue communiste révolutionnaire
trotskiste il a précisé que sa ville
compte actuellement quatre mille cinq
cents militants et qu'elle assurait une
présence militante devant plus de 400
entreprises
monsieur krivine vous vous en souvenez a
déjà été candidat en 1969 et en 1974
madame simone weil président de
l'assemblée de communautés européennes
s'est entretenue dans la matinée avec
monsieur raymond barre premier ministre
puis elle a été reçu à déjeuner par le
président de la république
les travaux de la session parlementaire
s'arrêteront normalement ce soir à
minuit
plusieurs textes sont encore en
discussion il y à cette procédure que
vous connaissez de la navette entre le
sénat l'assemblée nationale les députés
en tout cas espère bien ne pas avoir à
arrêter la pendule autrement dit ils
espèrent être en vacances dès ce soir
j'en viens toujours en attendant
monsieur debré l'enlèvement à
l'enlèvement de monsieur maury laribière
pour le moment la police ne dit rien
elle a toujours été dans ces affaires
d'enlèvements contre le paiement des
rançons
la famille au contraire qui est pour a
dit avoir reçu aujourd'hui un coup de
téléphone d'une personne se réclamant du
groupe action directe 27 28 mars 80 qui
ensuite a téléphoné à la fp
confirmant ce contact avec la famille je
vous rappelle que le délai fixé en
principe par les ravisseurs pour le
paiement de la rançon expire demain
et aussi que monsieur marie la rivière
avait été souffrant tous ces temps
derniers
notre envoyé spécial laurent massardier
fait le point et nous envoie un extrait
de ce qu'a dit le fils d'un industriel
il ya du nouveau j'ai un membre de ma
famille était contacté par un groupe qui
s'appelle 27 28 mars quatre actions
directes je crois et qui voulait me
parler j'en ai c'est un message très
rapide et ils ont l'air de revendiquer
l'attendaient ses membres de ma famille
qui l'a qu'il a eue parce que je n'étais
pas là par téléphone c'est tellement ma
famille qui l'a lu elle me l'a ils ont
laissé 20 secondes et ont raccroché au
site au nom de cette personne était
prise un petit peu au dépourvu
d'après ce que d'après ce qu'ils ont dit
parce qu'ils en fin de compte ils ont
parlé que cinq ou six secondes les
annuler le démenti qu est l formulé hier
soir l' agence france-presse
dans sa déclaration le fils de monsieur
maury laribière manuel un d'autre part
viennent assister sur le fait que sa
famille n'agissait pas en collaboration
avec la police et attendait des preuves
tangibles de la part des ravisseurs
les policiers quant à eux restent d'une
discrétion absolue sur les
investigations en cours
pourtant dans l'après midi on notait une
certaine agitation de la part des
enquêteurs
bien qu'il ne semble toujours pas croire
au caractère politique de l'enlèvement
le procureur de la république c'est
quand même déplacé d'angoulême pour
venir à la gendarmerie de confolens
alors action politique ou tout
simplement criminel
de toute façon comme le laissait
entendre le premier message des
ravisseurs
c'est sans doute demain 1er juillet que
les choses risquent d'évoluer et
rapidement le professeur jean bernard a
remis ce matin au chef de l'état son
rapport sur l'alcoolisme en france et
les premières propositions qu'il fait
pour une période de 10 ans afin de
lutter contre le terrible fléau
jean-bernard est au centre de l'émission
audition publique que va me mets juste
après la fin de ce journal en direct
pour question plaint jean pierre
elkabbach qui nous attend avec ses
invités au studio sans abri dont un
professeur bernard vous avez donc
respecter le délai de six mois que le
président de la république vous avez
donné pour lui présenter aujourd'hui des
recommandations et des propositions mais
alors tout de suite
alors qu'en france la consommation
d'alcool diminue et qu'elle augmente
partout ailleurs où l urgence à tous les
pans ce que vous appelez urgence il est
bien vrai qu'il y a fort heureusement
une diminution modérée de la
consommation d'alcool en france mais
nous avions été l'avant
sur les autres pays il trouve l avance
que nous n'aurons champion du monde
encore en ce qui concerne la
consommation d'alcool vous avez remis un
premier rapport
y aura-t-il un rapport définitif est ce
qu'il restera secret comme tant d'autres
apports non nous pensons que ce rapport
préliminaire qui a été remis ce matin
non par mon nom personnel et au nom du
groupe de travail que j'anime et que ce
rapport sera très prochainement rendu
public le rapport préliminaire
il sera suivi comme il l'avait indiqué
dans notre rapport plus fouillé plus
étoffé qui lui demandait à prononcer un
costume encore de travail alors
l'essentiel quelles sont les principales
propositions les principales
recommandations et mesures du groupe de
travail que vous avez présidé par alain
cible faut d'abord rappeler la gravité
du problème il ya en france 70 mineurs
par l'alcool chaque année est un malade
sur capoue sur trois dans les hôpitaux
français
les victimes de l'album pour lutter
contre ce fléau
nous avons proposé des mesures étalées
dans le temps nous pensons en effet que
les mesures brutales de type rubis
chamakh est notre client est efficace
ils ont proposé des mesures suivant
d'abord à moi extrêmement surpris de
voir que de nombreuses lois décrets et
règlements entièrement proposés
n'étaient pas appliquées exemple il n'ya
pas longtemps on a parlé de l'alcool au
volant d'une mesure excellent fondée sur
l'alcootest
il en est résulté plusieurs centaines de
morts de moins et puis après quelques
mois cette mesure est très vite tombé en
désuétude
les gens continuent à mourir y ait de
l'alcool notamment ali d'abord appliqué
ce qui me désole c'est déjà se dire non
le deuxièmement rétablir un équilibre
entre le revenu des français et le prix
de l'alcool
nous sommes aperçus que nous sommes
beaucoup construit pour ce travail
c'était une surprise que dans la période
où le revenu des français est passé de 1
à 3 le prix d'alcool est passé de 1 à 2
il paraît donc raisonnable qu'il ya une
sorte d'adaptation du prix de l'alcool
ce qu'est minimum sur le revenu des
français ce qui ferait une augmentation
du prix des alcools assez substantielle
ces substances yeux mais pas rapide mais
parra puis étaler dans le temps comme
tout ce que nous demandons
troisièmement à troisième mesure contre
la publicité
là encore nous sommes instruits nous
avons pris conscience avec beaucoup de
tristesse véritable scandale
c'est le lien qui s'est établi entre la
publicité le sport il y à toute une
série de publicité pour des boissons
alcooliques qui se font dans les stades
dans tous les endroits où la jeunesse
fait du sport nous considérons que la
cette situation est absolument
inacceptable que les morales
et matériellement inacceptable et nous
avons demandé beaucoup de vigueur que
premièrement dans toute la mesure du
possible et également étalé dans le
temps on supprime toute publicité sur
l'alcool et qu'on commence à voir très
vite par couper ce lien
scandale de qui existe entre le sport et
la publicité c'était un groupe de
rêveurs professeur bernard
qu'appelez-vous groupe de rêveurs que
vous présidiez parce que vous dites mais
ces mesures n'ont pas manqué le temps
dont je pense que les rêveurs sur
souvent très efficace et beaucoup de
mesures qu'ils proposent sont utiles
dans la vie il ya quelques années le
général de gaulle avait nommé membre
d'un groupe de travail s'était groupe
1985 premier d'avenir il y avait un
mélange à peu près à égalité de
statisticiens et de poètes si cela qui
très belle la vie a connu nous reverrons
tout à l'heure les mesures dans le
détail tout au long de l'émission mais
quatrièmement une action sur la
politique viticole là encore est allé
dans le sens qu'il y a on pourrait jouer
d'une phrase le produit à moins de 20 et
du un meilleur et tout une action
d'éducation et d'information qui est
très important sans compter l'aide
apportée aux très importants organismes
au comité d'entreprise comité national
auquel nous devons la diminution
observée depuis quelques jours je
rappelle qu'il s'agit là de propositions
qu'il y a le rôle du parlement et le
rôle surtout du gouvernement cacher
avant tout d'une volonté du gouvernement
et du parlement nous faisons que
proposez vous savez que l'opinion public
n'aime pas les trouble fêtes vous allez
vous heurter à l'hostilité
d'indifférence ou le mépris de l'opinion
en général non oui c'est déjà arrivé
mais vous savez moi j'ai un grand
entraînement avoir été minoritaire pour
commencer je peux l'espoir vous avez été
reçus à l'elysée léon zitrone l'a dit
tout à l'heure
quel accueil vous avez entendu pour les
propositions qui ont été faites et bien
j'ai eu bien entendu un accueil
extrêmement courtois mais j'ai le plus
que ça j'ai le sentiment que le
président était extrêmement intéressé
par ce problème est que il y avait de
grandes chances qu'il fasse progresser
et
le littoral commises dans de bonnes
conditions et dans les délais que nous
avons essayé quand vous parlez du délai
de temps ces 5 8 10 ans 12 ans sont au
taux de 8 ou 10 ans et que seules des
mesures étalées dans le temps des
chances de réussir à tout à l'heure je
peux dire que vous continuez vous même
personnellement dans cette lutte contre
l'alcoolisme
vous et votre groupe on nous a laissé
entendre ce net merci à tout à l'heure
pour des auditions publiques à 20h35
on ne jugera pas on ne débattra pas on
essaiera surtout d'écouter rendez vous
donc dans un quart d'heure à peu près
pour ce spécial question de temps sur un
sujet d'une importance capitale pour
notre avenir et celui de nos enfants
pendant cette interview que jean pierre
elkabbach je faisais et du professeur
bernard monsieur michel debré est arrivé
monsieur le premier ministre merci
d'être ici je vous poserai la question
qui brûle les lèvres de tout le monde
nous sommes à dix mois des
présidentielles pourquoi comme disent
les sportifs partir si tôt l'effort pour
convaincre les françaises et les
français est un effort qui sera long je
considère qu'il faut partir très vite si
je devrais votre candidature ne
risque-t-elle pas quand même de briser
le rpr ou en tout cas de faire naître
une crise grave au sein du mouvement
gaulliste je ne vois pas pourquoi je
crois avoir suffisamment prouvé depuis
bien des années
la ligne que je suivais et je ne vois
pas pourquoi je ne serais pas soutenu
mais votre candidature ne va-t-elle pas
affaiblir l'ensemble de la majorité
monsieur en quoi en quoi ea et ne
trouvez-vous pas cher si tron que cet
argument n'est pas un bon argument
il m'est arrivé de prendre des positions
et on disait vous allez faire plaisir
aux communistes et depuis cinq ou six
ans quand je parle de la lutte contre
l'inflation du chômage
quand je parle de l'insuffisance des
efforts faits on me dit vous allez